so for this video i'll be taking a
chronological look at zack sanders
justice league and i'll point out most
of the aspects of the movie that are
devoid of logic
and before you grab your pitchforks i'm
not trying to hate on the movie
this is just a fun critique that will
shine a light on different areas that
don't make sense
so first let's look at the mother boxes
they're supposed to be highly protected
and are something that steppenwolf
desperately wants
so why aren't the buildings there in
more secure
for example there's a massive hole in
the ceiling for the amazonian motherbox
strongholds
and for the atlantean one steppenwolf
just teleports in and comes up through
the bottom
do they ever question the security of
the compounds or test them
at least the amazonians have like 20
people just staring at it at all times
which in of itself is kind of funny
then we have the men who just bury the
mother box one foot into the ground and
call it a day
the amazonians are probably like no you
can't just bury the mother box in the
ground
steppenwolf can't find it if we can't
find it ironically though just
forgetting about it and losing it
seemed to be the best method in stopping
sevenwolf from finding the mother box
despite the pair of demons being able to
track their scent but
oh well so moving on from the mother
boxes for now we have a scene where
batman confronts
aquaman when the scene ends and aquaman
leaves we have a really weird moment
where the natives start singing
this mostly makes sense because they
seem to be worshipping him but
i don't know why zack snyder decided to
have a whole two-minute scene
of the natives singing and sniffing
aquaman's clothes
it was just very off-putting and avoid
logic to extend this moment for that
long
as one of the first impressions for the
movie this made me pretty worried for
the quality
but it did end up getting better so
going into wonder woman's introduction
she has to deal with some bad guys who
have a very generic motivation
to restore the world to the old ways by
killing a bunch of people
which in other words they're basically
just here so that wonder woman can have
an action scene
and going back to their motivation it
seems like all they want to do
is blow up this place so why doesn't the
main bad guy just detonate the explosive
device when wonder woman shows up
this is obviously nitpicky but it's
still devoid of logic from the villain's
perspective
they already want to die and it seems
like diana is killing them anyways
so why not just detonate the bomb also
looking at wonder woman's powers from
justice league to her own movies
is very inconsistent at no point in the
first wonder woman movie in 1984
is she ever fighting like this it looks
like she has on commando for modern
warfare too
because she's just lunging around
everywhere at super speed
also the physics in the scene are very
wonky
this shot of a guy rocking up towards
the ceiling from wonder woman barely
touching him
is hilarious the bad guys look
completely
weightless in the scene and it's very
noticeable
but it does make the scene much funnier
though i have to admit it
moving ahead later in the scene wonder
woman stops the bond from going off
and then she blows up the building
anyways with her gauntlets
way to go wonder woman that was
completely unnecessary
i don't know why she didn't just use her
super lunge ability to disarm the sky
i guess the filmmakers just wanted to
set up her using her gauntlets
despite it not making sense for her to
destroy part of the building to take out
one guy you okay princess
can i be like you someday
no i'm sorry little girl but you're not
a demigod like wonder woman
this isn't really devoid of logic but
it's so on the nose that it made me
laugh when i was watching it
so later on steppenwolf inevitably walks
on in through the big hole in the
ceiling
at the amazonian stronghold for the
mother box in general there's a lot of
aspects that don't make sense in this
scene
firstly while transporting the box out
of the building
the queen stops and has a dramatic
moment to talk to one of her fallen
comrades
like why the hell is she talking to this
girl she's literally surrounded by
parademons and is in immediate danger
she should be getting the hell out of
there because their sole objective is to
get the mother box away from steppenwolf
but i guess talking to a dying amazonian
is more important
after that they then seal the chamber
but what's the point in sealing it when
there's a massive hole in the ceiling
that they can just fly out of
if anything the amazonians are just
killing more of their own here
i also don't assume they survived
because for whatever reason
sealing the chamber somehow makes the
cliff self-destruct and fall into the
ocean
which in of itself i don't know how they
made that happen
then instead of getting the hell out of
there the queen decides to just stare at
the wreckage
like everyone should know steppenwolf is
fine he's literally flexing arrows out
of his armor and he's getting dog piled
by beefy woman
so some rubble should be nothing for him
and while staring at the wreckage
surprise surprise he emerges
great job he could have been running for
the hills by now
so for this scene i want to add a
suggestion to make it less devoid of
logic
i think it would have been much better
to have a darth vader style holloway
fight scene
of steppenwolf demolishing his way
through all the amazonians to get to the
mother box
action-wise it would be much more badass
and it would solve the whole ceiling
access issue
having a build up of him fighting
through the hallway would make the
progression of this action scene
much better and then when he gets there
they can try to extract the motherbox
so moving on we have another aquaman
scene
i like how he keeps throwing away his
shirts before he goes back into the
water
like where does he get all these shirts
from this just reminds me of the whole
hulk conundrum where he always has a new
pair of clothes after he hulks out
during the whole flashback sequence
where darkseid is trying to dominate
earth
he is for some reason not doing it with
any armor
as a result of that he just gets one
tapped by an axe and runs home
crying that is both stupid on darkseid's
part and on the filmmaker's standpoint
because how are we supposed to treat
darkseid as a menacing and intimidating
villain
when he immediately gets rolled i don't
know if he underestimated earth or
something
but not wearing armor in general is a
bad idea
you don't see thanos walking around
shirtless although i would assume some
fans may want to see that
also i like how one roman is giving
batman this whole 10 minute exposition
monologue
i'm just surprised he hasn't fallen
asleep yet so
moving on to the next scene we have
steppenwolf and tara getting people for
information
as to where the atlantean mother box is
for this moment i just wanted to point
out a macguffin device that steppenwolf
has that allows him to read people's
minds
like wow that's oddly convenient for the
plot
why does steppenwolf even ask this guy
where their mother box is
when he can just read his mind where is
it
no son of daughter of atlantis will ever
tell
in the scene where batman meets flash he
first says this
i know you have abilities i just don't
know what they are
and then he proceeds to throw a batarang
right at his face
if you were uncertain as to whether or
not he could actually see things in
bullet time
then why would you throw a batarang at
him that could have instantly killed him
i wonder if batman did this before and
showed up to the wrong person's
apartment and just headshotted them
so going back to the mother boxes and
the anti-life equation
there is a scene where steppenwolf has a
vision that the anti-life equation
is on earth however darkseid found this
out when he initially tried to conquer
earth
so did he just forget that the anti-life
equation was on our planet
on top of him just leaving the mother
boxes there
it doesn't make sense that he forgot
about the planet he lost to
especially since there are important
artifacts that he left behind
the only logical explanation i can think
of for this
was that darkseid was so embarrassed by
the defeat and chose to forget about it
and that doesn't paint the best picture
for a menacing villain
the movie also presents a fact that the
reason why the mother boxes were asleep
and didn't call out to the steppenwolf
was because superman was around and the
mother boxes were afraid of him
thus the mother boxes woke up when
superman died in the beginning
until superman died it's like they were
afraid of him
but what doesn't make sense is why the
mother boxes were not awake before
superman was even a thing
what was the big threat keeping the
mother boxes silent before superman
but yeah this is mostly just a plot hole
i like how batman
doesn't show up for the superman
confrontation the justice league just
leave him behind in the kryptonian ship
i don't know if that was intentional
because batman shows up later anyways
it's just weird because i imagine batman
was like hawkeye in age of ultron when
he got left behind
nobody would know nobody
moving ahead to the end of the scene
where steppenwolf steals the last
motherbox
batman shows up late to the party again
poor guy nobody is transporting him
around quickly so he's always late
after this point in the movie it goes
full tilt towards epic
action i didn't really find anything
else to be that devoid of logic during
these action scenes
and it was just a really fun time the
flash running into the past
makes the last third of the movie
outstanding
but looking at the ending of the movie
they opt for a lord of the rings-esque
epilogue where the movie has a bunch of
different endings
that's mostly fine but including an
entire 10 minute scene from the
nightmare premonition
instead of just a small teaser was a bit
much
especially since the movie is 4 hours
long
then after that zack snyder for some
reason throws martian hunter in a really
awkward scene where batman doesn't even
want to be talking to him
i'm sorry who are you again it's just a
really weird way to end the movie and i
would say this is partially devoid of
logic on a creator's standpoint
besides it just being fan service but
yeah that's basically it
i thought the movie was pretty fun but
it is weighed down by a lot of
exposition and origin stories if the
mother boxes and the antagonists were
already established like with the
infinity stones and thanos
then i think this movie would have a
much easier job in telling its story
because they have a lot of leg work to
do in terms of exposition
so yeah let me know what you thought
about the movie in the comments and if
you like this video then check out my
other devoid of logic videos in the end
screen